SPEAKER 1: Howdy.
Quick question.
Does Dialogflow CX integrate
with telephone providers?
SPEAKER 2: Yes, it does.
SPEAKER 1: Can I learn more
about the IVR features?
SPEAKER 2: Sure, then
stay tuned to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: For a full
voice experience,
your Dialogflow CX
agent can be integrated
with various
conversation platforms
such as Avaya, Genesys, Mitel,
Five9, Vonage, and more.
These providers offer a
user interface for callers
and pass their questions
through Dialogflow's API.
It's important to note that
every platform's integration
handles interactions in
their own unique way.
So depending on the
telephony provider you use,
you will need to review
their specific documentation.
So let's take a tour.
When we dive into
Dialogflow CX's console,
on the left side we
click the Manage tab
and scroll down to the
section called Integrations.
Under the One-click
Telephony header,
you will find partner built-in
telephony integrations
that were created
by Google partners
in collaboration with Google.
The following
partners are listed
as of the making of this video,
which are Avaya and AudioCodes.
There are also
independent integrations
that are not built in that
are created by organizations
and individuals.
They are built using
the Dialogflow API.
And as a friendly
heads up, when you
need support for any
telephony integration,
the partners are the folks
that will assist you.
With that being said,
the overall process
will be to build your
Google Cloud project,
enable the Dialogflow
API within your project,
and then create a
Dialogflow CX agent.
Since most agent conversations
are built within many flows
and pages in mind, you
will also typically build
a webhook service to
generate a dynamic response
based on your business' logic.
You will also most
likely need to keep
in mind certain
pieces of information
for the integration, such as
your project ID, agent ID,
and/or the API key.
IVR settings can be found
at three different levels
in Dialogflow--
at the agent level, flow
level, and page level.
For starters, you must first
enable the Agent Level Settings
and select the
Speech and IVR tab.
Then, under the
Advanced settings,
toggle the Enable
Advanced Settings on.
There are three
features to note.
The first is called end of
speech sensitivity, which
helps determine how sensitive
the speech end pointing should
be when a caller
finishes speaking.
And it uses Google Cloud speech.
Next is barge-in, which
allows the speaker
to interrupt the agent.
This is helpful
so that the caller
doesn't have to wait to hear
the full response from the agent
in order to speak.
Or another way of
looking at it is,
if you disable the
barge-in setting,
the agent would only begin to
listen to a caller's speech
until it has completely
finished playing its response.
And last is the Google
Cloud Storage URI,
which enables you to reference
a Google Cloud Storage path back
in order to access
pre-recorded audio.
After enabling IVR settings
at the agent level,
you can also customize
IVR settings further
on a per flow level.
You can do this by hovering
over a flow's name,
click the dots icon, and
choose Flow Settings.
Then you toggle Enable
Advanced Speech Settings.
By enabling IVR features
at the flow level,
they override the
agent level IVR
settings it was defaulting to.
This is extremely useful if
you want to have different IVR
settings in a multiflow agent.
The third level of IVR
settings resides on each page.
You can access these by hovering
over a page, clicking the dots,
then selecting Page Settings.
And same as a flow,
a page's IVR settings
will default to the agent's
settings or flow settings
unless you specifically select
Customize at the page level.
Now, you may be
thinking, when might
I want to use the page
and flow level settings?
This depends on your use case.
For example, let's say as
a user dictates and pauses
in between numbers such as, my
account number is 123 [PAUSE]
45 [PAUSE] 6789.
The user benefits from
extending the timeout,
so you may want to make sure
that the timeout setting isn't
too short or the user
will be cut off, which
is very rude in conversations.
Furthermore, if I stayed
silent because I didn't
know my account number
and I was looking for it,
then tweaking the
no-speech timeout setting
will allow the agent to help
me by further prompting me
on where to get
that account number.
And there you have it, a quick
walk through of IVR features
and settings in Dialogflow CX.
I left some helpful links
in this video's description
if you would like to
learn more or if you
missed any of our previous
videos on Dialogflow CX.
I hope to see you in the next
episode of Deconstructing Chat
Bots.
If you like this
video and would like
to see more of this
type of content,
it helps to like and
subscribe to our channel.
Cheers, and thank
you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]